revenir malgré la peur et malgré les
risques pour retourner dans son village
nadia dû signer une décharge car les
troupes russes ont miné le terrain avant
leur départ
nous avons signé les papiers au poste
parce que si nous faisons exploser non
ne deviendront pas les soldats pour
responsable
pour ceux qui comme elles veulent
revenir l'armée tente de déminer le
terrain
pas que
oui les soldats russes piège les bagues
les bijoux les colliers
ils creusent un trou en dessous il place
un explosif
même chose avec les jouets d'enfants et
les corps de leurs propres soldats
il piège tout ce qui attire l'attention
les choses qui pourraient être ramassés
pour éviter les explosions les habitants
développent des techniques de détection
artisanales comme ce boulanger venus se
réapproprier ce qu'il reste de son
commerce y ait su aller au cahier
sculpture jean utilisé une corde avec un
crochet de suivre vous devez la lancée
il a tiré sur le sol syrien explosent
alors vous pouvez avancer de 5 mètres
supplémentaires même chose pour la porte
vous utilisez le crochet pour l'ouvrir
au total depuis le début de la guerre le
service de déminage ukrainien a déjà
retiré plus de 48000 munitions dont plus
de 2000 bombe